hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round six of this
year's uh Norway chess it is aliantari
versus Magnus Carlsen and this is the
Armageddon game we've shown the only
game that finished in classical chess
Fabi won a very nice game but now it's
time to check out what happened in
Armageddon uh tari has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to e for their
classical game was uh uh the title
looked okay in the opening that Magnus
had probably two maybe not completely
winning but two you know uh sort of
winning uh attempts at some point but he
didn't go for either of them and in the
end uh it just fizzled out into a draw
uh so let's see what happened here E4 uh
Pawn to E5 with Knight to F3 Knight to
C6 and now Bishop the C for the Italian
game is on the board in the classical
game day I played the Sicilian Knight to
F6 the two knights defense and now Pawn
to D3 with Bishop D7 uh both players
castle and now a knight to C3 we have D6
and pawn to A3 I saw all been seen
before nothing new here Bishop to G4
upon the H3 captures captures and not
Knights the D4 and here just Queen back
to D1 if this was played let's say 150
years ago in the uh in the days of Paul
morphy we would even see a queen to G3
here you know it wouldn't be unheard of
uh because look at this for example
Knight captures on C2 attacks The Rook
okay Rook B1 you're gonna Advance
um the pawn here let's say Knight back
to D4 now Bishop to H6 and already white
is having a very nice attack here for
the price of 1.98 defense against
Checkmate okay you've defended where the
white would be able to do something or
not here objectively not but you know if
it was a quicker time format even
quicker than Armageddon maybe we would
see it interestingly it has never been
even attempted in this position but okay
Queen back to D1 uh Pawn to C6 and now
Bishop back to A2 and so the bishop will
not be in range of the pawns when they
start marching forward and also in the
future you might even let's say you
develop the bishop you move the Rook you
put the bishop even on B1 and then you
grab hold of this diagonal even this is
possible so Knight D6 with knights the
E2 and down Magnus uh Atari shifts the
attention to the king side uh he wants
to get the Knight to G3 to F5 but that
means he also leaves the control of the
center and the Magnus advances the pawn
pawn to D5 Knight to G3 and now the game
has been reached before the sipenko
headed against Daniel dubov uh two years
ago and the game ended in a draw doop of
continued with G6 here but Magnus went
Queen to C7 and it is now as of move uh
13 then we have a completely new game so
quantity three uh we have Rook 8 to d8
and now Queen to F3 developing the queen
uh hoping to connect Rooks soon with
rook fd8 and now okay you could consider
Knight to F5 right away that it was
Bishop to E3 First bishop to C5 Magnus
counters the bishop and now Knight to F5
Magnus kicks away the Knight Pawn to G6
and now just Queen to G3 it would be
maybe a bit safer to go back with the
Knight but tari is looking for adventure
here Queen to G3 now comes Knight to H5
attacking Titus Queen and knights the H6
with check and okay you don't have to
worry all that much the nice Knight is
nicely defended King G7 and now Queen to
G4 I thought he could even look for
as some sort of a draw here with Knight
to F5 check but he lost uh all of all of
the all of the encounters so far he
wants uh he wants to play for the win uh
with the white pieces of course and now
okay you either uh draw here by force or
magnets would probably go for King and
avoid the draw let's say queen to H4 now
Bishop captures on E3 F captures an E3
and now Pawn to F6 and it's uh you know
it's a fine position for both white and
black but instead Queen to G4 a most
adventurous idea and here Magnus just
played Bishop captures on E3 now uh uh
you could even consider instead of this
bishop captures on E3 and the immediate
Knight E2 F4 this looks very nice point
is that let's say Bishop captures on C5
King captures and H6 okay go back Bishop
to E3 not just King back to G7 so black
those Knights are are looking very
impressive now uh but okay Magnus win
for Bishop captures on E3 right away uh
we have Knights the F5 with check King
to h8 and now F captures an E3 opening
up the rook's f file and of course if
the pawn captures you will be able to
capture the Knight and interestingly
that's exactly what happens but not
quite uh in the way that I've mentioned
it the G captures on F5 is played by
Magnus and now tari has to play Queen
captures on H5 but he played e captures
an F5 maybe it can be played but it's a
lot more complicated I will just show
you what happens if Queen captures on H5
it's actually a very simple line where
everything gets traded off for example
f4e capture Sun D5 C captures on D5 and
now Pawn to D4 making e for impossible
because the D5 Pawn will be hanging so
here you will play Knight G7 kick away
the queen queen G5 and now whatever
black plays probably Queen to B6 uh uh X
Ring that E3 Pawn even D captures an E5
Queen captures an E3 with tracking to H1
Queen characters anifa Queen captures on
F4 and everything gets traded off equal
material but white is a little bit
better white has a bishop against the
Knight and the white king is uh it is a
bit safer than the black king however
tari went he captures on F5 and okay it
makes sense you grab another Pawn you
advance you are still attacking the two
knights but now Knight eat the F4 and
this is now uh very annoying for Aryan
as The Rook to Jade is coming and then
how are you defending the G2 Pawn it's
okay he captures once it's the only
thing you can do he captures an F4 with
Knight captures on F4 and now Queen to
H4 at least when Rook to G8 comes a
queen to F6 check will force Rook to G7
and then the Rook will be stuck on this
diagonal you will not be able to capture
on G2 so that's the plan but Magna still
goes for it Rook to G8 and now Queen to
F6 with check also G4 could have been
considered but the 31st wants to
paralyzed The Rook Rook to G7 Pawn to D
for now and here Magnus plays Knight
captures on H3 a much cleaner way would
be just to Rook the E8 preparing E4 also
defending on E5 and not a lot to do here
with rookie D1 just spawn to E4 the
Knight is now nicely defended by the
queen and black will always be better
here however magnets went for Knight
captures on H3 uh check instead he has a
different plan King to H1 and not Knight
back to G5
and now the Knight can come to E4 and
then to G3 and here you should just play
decal you can't play D captures on E5
obviously because of Knight to E4
attacks the queen and also Knight the G3
check is coming uh but what you should
play is Queen captures on E5 and this is
pretty much the only thing you have left
here as white uh then let's say we trade
everything off captures captures Knight
comes the E4 threatens to come to G3 but
Rook F4 uh still sort of holds for white
however after this uh Rook 8 to E1 move
or rather after Knight the G5 Rook 8 to
E1 was played by tari not going for
captures right away he first prepares it
but now Magnus is completely winning uh
but you have to be very very precise to
find it feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
H file is open also one of the reasons
why Magnus really wanted to capture that
pawn on H3 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook to D6
this is how we do it uh point is that
okay now the E5 Pawn is not defended
anymore uh but you don't care you really
just want to play Rook to H6 and there's
nothing better uh Queen captures an E5
was played now comes Rook to H6 with
check King to G1 and now another
beautiful Knight to the H3 with check
forcing the king to go back to the H
file King to H1 and now Knight the F4
with check there's an even quicker way
to do it Queen captures and E5 is is
even quicker because after d captures
there's Knight to F for a discovery and
after King to G1 now the G2 Pawn is
undefended as you've traded queens and
The Rook captures and G2 will be
Checkmate a similar thing happened in
the game Knight to F4 was first played
uh now again uh this is a discovery by
The Rook King to G1 and now okay you
can't
you can deliver Checkmate because the
rook and G7 is pinned but you can
eliminate the source of the pin and that
is the queen on E5 Magnus played Queen
captures on E5 and it was in this
position on move 33 that Aryan tari
resigned to the game and another victory
for Magnus cross and in Armageddon uh in
this round six of this year's Norway
chest so here you of course resign
because you're either down a queen or
you're getting checkmated but most
likely both so it makes sense to resign
here and it wasn't a matter of time
travel they both had plenty of time
Magnus had like uh four minutes on the
clock that he had almost two minutes on
the clock so it was like you know a huge
time trouble or anything it was just uh
you know tari played a great game at
some point he he missed a few moves and
the Magnus uh you know just uh took over
the entire board so that's uh regarding
the game now regarding the the current
standings there we have it after six
rounds Fabi still in the lead as he won
a very nice game if you have haven't
seen it do check out my previous video
Hikaru trailing in second place with 11
points then alireza and gukash with
Aiden have shock there with eight Magnus
Carlsen and Wesley so with seven and a
half Anish with seven Notre back with
six and Aryan tari is still in last
place with three points and it's
incredible even though Magnus won all of
his encounters after that loss in round
one at the Fabi uh it's just that he
lost he won all of the games in
Armageddon he did not win any games in
classical that's why you know he's um
you know grabbing a little little bits
of points and uh otherwise he would have
been much further ahead but what are you
gonna do you have to win in classical uh
here we have uh the uh the mutual Mutual
scores defeated Anish in Armageddon
Aryan lost the Magnuson armaged and
alireza lost the Hikaru in Armageddon uh
Shakira lost the Wesleyan Armageddon and
another Beck lost that brutal game at
the Fabi if you haven't seen it do check
it out my previous video and sorry I
just uh accidentally removed myself and
here are the
uh here are the ratings so let me just
improve this a little bit there we go
here are the live ratings so Magnus of
course still in first button down 14
points that's that's a lot as he he
can't seem to win a game in classical
Fabi up 13 points he again overtakes
Hikaru as world number two something
that we've also discussed in the
previous video that now we're gonna see
a new world number two every day so
that's something that we have to get
used to and it's not like okay okay we
have a new world number two no it's
we're gonna have a new world number two
every day so uh Hikaru and uh Fabiano
the big winners here and okay there's
also some movement down the board book
is also on plus three but nothing
nothing spectacular so we'll see what
happens a few more rounds in this
tournament uh should be should be very
interesting uh so yeah that's the little
uh that's the game and a little bit of
extra info on the side hope you enjoyed
that uh I would like to thank uh karibi
uh uh Michael zacarias David and Brandon
fukuda and Ricky Johnson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this spectacular event until it finishes
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day